[Musique]
de nouvelles portes s'ouvrent à
mantes-la-jolie que vous soyez de la
famille van helsing ou non il vous
faudra résoudre de nombreuses énigmes
vampirique là on est dans la classe de
départ de la salle de dracula donc on
est sur une salle qui est accessible dès
7 ans jusqu'à 6 joueurs
cette salle a été pensée pour s'adapter
en fonction du joueur
par exemple un joueur qui pourra avoir
trop peur dans la salle la difficulté
d'adapter une salle qui fait déjà des
cons qui parmi le jeune public le
bâtiment est assez récent et décors sont
vraiment frappant et le si l'ambiance
avec la musique fête qui est très peu de
lumière ça aide beaucoup dans l'ambiance
qui est du coup vraiment sympa j'aime
bien aussi quand il ya des mécanismes
très originaux et la haye avaient
presque que ça moi je suis originaire de
mantes et j'ai toujours voulu parce que
je n'ai pas eu une activité de loisir
donc on est là avant tout pour s'amuser
la question qui revient le plus souvent
c'est la salle est effectivement est
accessible dès 7 ans mais les adultes 10
bah ouais mais là ça l'avait trop c'est
facile pour nous donc on n'a pas envie
de faire et c'est là que ça devient
drôle parce que des fois des enfants
vont beaucoup plus que des adultes
ouvert depuis le samedi 23 avril minos
évasion propose un petit bonus pour les
enquêteurs les plus hardis sur le
lancement on a un concours secret dans
le local quand le joueur passe la porte
il a des énigmes à résoudre et le joueur
qui arrive à résoudre toutes ces énigmes
pourra gagner un chèque de 1000 euros au
total il y aura quatre salles dans
l'établissement de lignes sont déjà
tracées
le manoir du comte dracula et une
seconde pièce à venir dans l'univers du
film d'animation vice versa enfin les
deux dernières au sous sol dont les
thèmes restent encore bien gardé